my name is victor i arrived
in montreal in january 2019 indirectly from
france
i am working on a project that aims to
precisely use
artificial intelligence to simulate images
of smaug floods and
forest fires to raise awareness and
bring people closer  the consequences of
global warming on our
daily lives global warming
and its consequences such as
floods it's not that elsewhere it
can also be here and in any
case our actions here have
consequences elsewhere in time
and space so  it is important
to be able to realize
it was to work with with the
choice because I greatly respect the
quality of his research but above all
his
political commitment to want to dedicate part
of his research time to these
studies  is the fight against
climate change
and then more generally ali has for the
good of humanity
first of all is to do it  in
working conditions which are very
pleasant we have very beautiful ideas of
premises which we take advantage of in mans with the
empty co but which are nevertheless of very
high quality we have access to
computing resources which are very
useful and above all we have access  to a
work environment that allows us
to have a community that allows
us to almost always have an
answer to our question where people to
whom we can ask for references to
go and read
better understand the subject on which we are
working and we can very easily
find collaborations people
to work with and share
research
[Music]